there were a couple interesting things
that came out this weekend that don't
quite
fit the corporate press narrative and i
think it's
important to show so first off um hamas
and these are the terrorists basically
that run the gaza strip
okay they run this tiny little piece of
land that's just a sliver
of the entirety of israel basically that
is and i talk about this all the time
that israel is basically the size of new
jersey this is just a tiny little strip
that before 1967 was part of egypt it
was never part of a place
known as palestine that had a prime
minister or president or anything of
that nature
well they had a victory parade this
weekend and i thought we'd show you this
victory parade because you're not going
to see this on mainstream media
but it's quite curious because i thought
israel was bombing children
and there was a genocide and ethnic
cleansing and all that stuff
seemed odd that you would run a victory
parade but here it is you may want to
lower your volume a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
i would imagine they were singing about
peace and coexistence and that sort of
thing
if you don't think that that's odd if if
they were
you know ethnically cleansed and all of
the horrible things that everyone said
israel was doing a week ago and now
they're having victory parades
also really reminds me of auschwitz
doesn't it that's the other thing they
always say it's like the concentration
camps
yeah yeah you ever see pictures from the
concentration camps pretty sure they
weren't
driving around with missiles and
everybody looked sort of fat and healthy
and
all the rest of it but then
if you don't think that's odd enough
that that doesn't sort of fit the
narrative this video
came out this is gaza's packed beaches
this weekend
[Music]
[Music]
well there seems to be a narrative
buster for you right genocide open air
prison
it's like auschwitz they're just
enjoying the day
on the beach which shows you that what's
happening on the ground is very
different
than what you're seeing in the news and
the reason i showed you all this was
because then
this weekend in brooklyn you know the
these black lives matter and antifa
rioters protesters whatever you want to
call them they've now
had this intersectional bond in hell
with the palestinian activists and here
in new york city at the brooklyn bridge
we've got some pictures we'll throw to
you
they had massive protests where they
basically shut down
the brooklyn bridge so you've got the
people actually in gaza
on the beach trying to go about living
their lives you've got the
hamas terrorists a self-described i mean
they're a self-described terrorist group
they want to wipe out all the jews right
not just those mean israelis all the
jews
they're having a victory parade they've
got people on the beaches but here
our activist which is exactly what
rashida talib wanted she wanted to
combine
these you know quote-unquote oppressions
so now you've got in some ways
are activists here in new york city at
the brooklyn bridge
in many ways being more radical than
the people on the ground in gaza and
there is a reason for that that goes
beyond just what our awful
progressive politicians are saying the
new york times this is i mean this is
just so fascinating you really got to
pay attention to this
the new york times had an opinion piece
a couple days ago
called the myth of coexistence in israel
and we're going to show you the map here
so this is a
map that they showed in this piece that
ran in the new york times and i've
covered this a couple times on the show
but that map is complete fabrication
msnbc used to show that map and they had
to retract it
what you're seeing there on the left
when they say all of that is palestine
the implication is that there was a
country
known as palestine okay there wasn't you
guys all know this there was
the british mandate of palestine for
many years and then before that there
was the ottoman empire and in the place
of palestine there were no people
known as palestinians there were arabs
that lived there and there were
druze and jews not druids from
space balls there were probably some of
them there too um
so that's the first map that you're
looking at then the second map is
basically what you're seeing there
is the 1947 partition plan that's what
they could have had they could have had
two states these the jews
said yes we'll take it the arabs said no
then launched a war
and lost then the third map they show
here is complete fabrication because the
green in the third map here
on the right what the big chunk on the
right that's jordan that was jordan then
and on the left as i said before the
gaza strip that was part
of egypt then on the fourth map here
they're trying to imply that now
palestine is smaller that's starting in
1994 when the israelis for the first
time gave
palestinian people self-identified
palestinian people
an area to control of their own so the
israelis are the first one they gave it
to him i know this history gets all
annoying and by the way bill maher you
know i've been a little critical of bill
maher
lately because it's like he's a lefty
but he's not completely insane and i
would say he's mostly he's good on free
speech but
he actually basically repeated a a
complete show that i did
about two weeks ago uh laying out the
history of the area and i
will give credit where it was due
whether his guys watched my show and
decided to do it or not
he actually did a nice defense of israel
and it was nice to hear from a liberal
perspective because it's been so bad
but in any event so the new york times
runs a piece
called the myth of coexistence in israel
showing the map that is a complete
fabrication
and then finally because people pushed
back they had to admit it was basically
a piece of art
so this is from honest reporting but
arguably far worse than the piece itself
was the times choice of a graphic
one that spreads the tendacious lie that
between 1948 and 1967
palestine shrunk and this disappearance
continues up until the present day
and here's the the amazing part when
pressed the times
deputy opinion editor patrick healy
submitted that the graphic
should not be taken literally this
image was used as art atop an opinion as
a essay and we felt that the art image
helped illustrate her
arguments in a statement yes a
fictitious
art did illustrate the written word in
the fictitious piece
the new york times is genuinely evil it
is it is a place of evil it is not a
place of journalism
and if you think that that's excusable
that they can put
up a map to correlate with an opinion
piece and then
after and nobody reads the retractions
that's why i thought this was important
to do nobody reads the retractions
afterwards they say oh
the picture we put up that everyone sees
the picture and they see the headline
very few people read the
the articles or the opinion pieces it
was just art
it didn't have anything to do with an
actual map or factualness
oh these people are just ridiculous